They're coming
stay hidden
or we will not survive
leave us alone when the time comes he must
be trained like you trained his father
you still want kenobi
he's gone
maybe you've been looking in the wrong places
I want every lowlife and
bounty hunter to squeeze him
you can't escape him
Hello there everyone this is going to be my
obi-wan kenobi trailer video happy star wars
day may the fourth be with you they finally gave
us some new footage and footage of darth vader
himself if you're brand new to the channel
i'll be doing videos for all the episodes
be sure to subscribe to get everything remember
they made a change they actually made the first
two episodes drop during star wars celebration
a couple days later so the first two episodes
will drop the first week and then after that
it'll be weekly but the building this one is
like the first regular trailer so there'll
be a bunch more trailers after this i think
that's because they're just giving you the other
side of the equation darth vader himself hayden
christensen coming back to star wars the really
cool thing that you've probably seen in real
life happening the past couple of weeks is that
hayden christensen himself has been talking about
coming back to the role of darth vader anakin
skywalker as well as you and mcgregor talking
about the series in general and what's going on
with season two previously they build it like a
one-off like they were just going to do one season
but now you mcgregor's been talking about coming
back and doing more obi-wan kenobi seasons
after this during this part of the timeline
and hayden christensen said this is really only
the beginning of him coming back as darth vader
so i think we all had the theory that when they
cast him as darth vader during this that we'd
also see him in anakin skywalker flashbacks
and also probably showing up during the
ahsoka series when they do those episodes next
year in whatever flashbacks they do for that
anakin i won't leave you not this time
then you will die so if you're big fans of the
darth vader comic book series this is probably the
closest you'll get to a legit darth vader series
even though they didn't really feature him during
the first teaser and you're just getting
a little bit of him now what they do show
us during this trailer is him just putting his
armor on after coming out of his back the tank
inside his castle his fortress on mustafar because
the big facility that they keep flying to this
giant black fortress is called the fortress
inquisitorius it's where the emperor kept all
the inquisitors and trained them in the dark side
arts and where he tortured a lot of jedi that he
brought back looking for more information
they also visit the fortress inquisitorius
during the jedi fall and order a game so a
lot of you probably remember it from that
that was just on a different moon in the same
mustafar system so darth vader himself is kind
of stewing over in the dark side in his own
castle here on mustafar while the inquisitors
are really really close by but the funny thing
is that he actually never really cared about
the inquisitors in fact he actually really hated
the idea of somebody potentially replacing him
in the emperor just killing him off the same way
that he did to his previous apprentice darth maul
even though technically darth maul didn't
wind up dying till way later in the timeline
he's supposed to not show up during this series
there isn't supposed to be any kind of darth maul
i don't think that they're lying about that there
might be some loose references to that if you want
to see the final rematch of obi-wan kenobi versus
darth maul he doesn't really wind up killing him
to the events of star wars rebels which is like
a year or so before the events of a new hope
by that time he started to look more like the
alec guinness version of obi-wan kenobi like old
man obi-wan kenobi because so many of you are
asking about other big characters cameoing and
we're getting the mandalorian season 3 supposedly
by the end of the year a lot of you are asking if
grogu is going to show up during this part of
the timeline because if you didn't know grogu
and anakin skywalker are meant to be about the
same age it's just that grosgu came to the jedi
temple a couple years before anakin skywalker
so they would have encountered each other during
their childhood at the jedi temple before order 66
but what we learned during the book of boba fett
flashback scenes where we get grogu's backstory
with luke skywalker is that by this time he'd
been hiding out hiding himself from the force and
has slowly been forgetting his teachings because
he hadn't been using them so 10 years had gone by
so during this time he's probably hiding somewhere
deep in the outer rim so i'm not expecting to see
him but they could reference him in some loose
way yoda's still very much alive obviously
emperor palpatine is still very much active
so we'll see if they reference either of them
or if they wind up referencing groku in any way
a lot of you probably detected a lot of the
familiar music cues during this like obviously
it's duel the fates because that is a big anakin
skywalker theme duel the fates from phantom
menace is literally a reference to a duel over the
fate of anakin skywalker that obi-wan kadobi and
qui-gon jinn wind up losing to the emperor himself
little bit of darth vader's theme little bit of
the actual obi-wan kenobi theme and a little bit
of the classic imperial march played during this
too from empire strikes back they did compose
a lot of completely new music for the obi-wan
kenobi episodes but john williams came back to
compose the actual obi-wan kenobi theme because if
you can believe it during the original trilogy he
never actually created an original obi-wan kenobi
theme just for that character like he did for yoda
or for luke skywalker but john williams just came
back to do the obi-wan kenobi theme that one piece
of music all the regular episodes were done by a
completely different person one of the other cool
things they show you with this is an encounter
that obi-wan kenobi has with owen lars obviously
joel edgerton came back to play the character
if you remember that last scene from revenge
of the sith where he drops off luke skywalker
with owen and brew large all the same actors from
that scene came back except for the baby obviously
different actor playing luke skywalker but you
see obi-wan kenobi arguing with him about how
luke skywalker will eventually need to be trained
in the force because he's so naturally talented
and so powerful so potentially powerful you know
and lars throws anakin skywalker back in his face
like you trained his father how dare you leave
us alone when the time comes he must be trained
like you trained his father it seems like they'll
give you more owen large backstory and explain why
it is that he hated the idea of force sensitive
so much why he didn't want luke to be trained and
a lot of that will have to do with what happens
with the inquisitors the grand inquisitor coming
to tatooine looking for obi-wan kenobi so if it
wasn't clear even though they kind of tease you
with the idea of the inquisitors maybe finding out
about luke skywalker they're not really completely
trying to break the timeline and the whole idea
is that darth vader didn't fully learn that luke
skywalker was alive and his son in the potential
of leia till much later in the timeline he learned
luke skywalker's secret identity before the events
of empire strikes back but just a little while
before empire strikes back so he came into that
movie knowing that luke skywalker was his son
that's why when they fought each other on
cloud city it seems like his moves were so
basic because he wasn't really trying to kill luke
skywalker he was trying to turn into the dark side
luke join me on the dark side of the force
my son it is the only way it looks like they
saw all your grand inquisitor tweets last time
because his head looks way more accurate even
though the eyes are just a little bit different
i think they tuned him up just a little bit to
make him a little more accurate to the depiction
that you saw during the star wars rebels episodes
the whole idea is that they've come to tatooine
searching for obi-wan kenobi on the orders of
darth vader you hear the inquisitors yelling about
him over and over you won't escape him they're
talking about darth vader but you also hear them
communicating with darth vader during the trailer
when they say you still want him referring to
darth vader wanting obi-wan kenobi this character
here is named riva they're calling her the third
sister she's a brand new character she's not from
the canon before they just introduced her for the
tv show the other character is meant to be the
fifth brother i believe he's played by son kang
who most of you remember from the fast and furious
series the fifth brother was featured during the
star wars rebels episode so you have probably seen
a version of him before the grand inquisitor has
this crazy backstory too so he was actually one
of the jedi temple guardians on coruscant for a
long time dave filoni actually said that he was
meant to be one of the temple guardians who was
escorting ahsoka during her trial when she was
much younger and wound up leaving the jedi order
and during that trial he started to have some
misgivings about the jedi order just in general
and then by the time order 66 rolled around later
in the timeline he'd really started to dislike the
jedi order so when order 66 was actually going
down when anakin was raiding the temple that's
when he sort of switched sides and helped
the emperor execute order 66. that was when
he officially turned to the dark side the other
planet that they show you during this trailer that
looks kind of like the hong kong casino planet
with all the neon signs is called daiyu it's also
brand new they haven't used it before in the star
wars canon before it seems like obi-wan kenobi
goes there to help someone during the course of
this series like there's some problem that gives
him a big cult action that causes him to leave
tatooine there are a lot of people that think that
the reason for that has something to do with the
young version of leia because if you have a young
version of luke why wouldn't you also bring a
young version of leia but it also sounds like he's
trying to help other jedi too because you hear him
speaking stay hidden stay safe so he's talking to
other jedi who have been in hiding or other force
sensitives in hiding since the end of order 66 you
also see some signs scribbled into walls here on
this other planet too so it sounds like we're just
gonna see a bunch of these other jedi that have
been hiding out which it also seems like kumail
nanjiani is playing like he's wearing jedi robes
i don't know who he's playing if he's someone
from the canon or if he's gonna be a brand new
character they're just introducing for the series
it also seems like there's this big fight at the
fortress inquisitoria so maybe obi-wan kenobi
winds up raiding it to save someone and maybe
that's where the big fight with darth vader winds
up happening there is supposed to be a big rematch
between obi-wan kenobi and darth vader there's
been a lot of talk about this because previously
i think a lot of people believe that the canon
stated that their first rematch after revenge of
the sith on mustafar where he basically turned
him into human charcoal brickhead was during a new
hope on the death star the circle is now complete
when i left you i was but the learner now i am the
master the way they've explained it for the series
is they just kind of modified the interpretation
of that line just a little bit so technically this
will be the last fight that they have unless they
do a season 2 and there is some kind of rematch
next season either way there's going to be a lot
of obi-wan kenobi fighting darth vader during this
part of the timeline about 10 years after revenge
of the sith darth vader himself is supposed to
be the most powerful that he's ever been both of
them are still relatively young during this period
even though obviously obi-wan kenobi much older
than darth vader himself but the reason why you
only see them putting on the one mechanical arm is
because he'd only lost one of his arms on mustafar
the emperor himself actually cut off darth
vader's other hand as a sort of penance for the
destruction of the first death star he chopped off
his other hand for darth vader's failure to stop
the rebels from destroying the first death star
i will do more bonus videos for the series we'll
get more trailers as we get a little bit closer
there's just so much to talk about it's gonna be
a lot of fun to do episodes for this all my big
doctor strange two videos my post credit scenes
full easter eggs breakdown of the movie will start
posting in the next couple of days make sure you
enable alerts for my channel so you don't miss
those and go see that movie as soon as possible
do not wait to go see it they just released the
moon knight finale you can click here for my full
moon knight episode 6 finale video in easter
eggs and click here for my doctor strange
2 review video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and may the 4th be with you!